hey everyone it's gerald here and today
i'll be sharing another cool product i
just received what i have here is the
brand new nano leaf lines and you might
have seen this product before if you
watch twitch frequently pretty much
every streamer seems to have the brand
as part of their aesthetic for this
video i'll be going through the process
from start to finish to give you an idea
of what the entire process is like and
given my thoughts along the way about
the nano leaf lines before we begin help
us out by giving us a like and subscribe
to our channel for more content just
like this and then here we have the
starter kit it gives you nine lines in
total which allows for plenty of designs
if you need more nano leaf sells
additional lines in a pack of tree and
it connects up to 18 lines in total per
power supply to help you expand the
realms of possibility we also have
connecting joints and uncovers this
helped form the bridge that help you
connect each line together it's made of
durable plastic and allows you to snap
the lines into each joint with a little
force at moment it's a bit hard to press
down but this plastic seems to take a
lot of abuse thankfully in my setup
process no joints and lines were harmed
along the way the most important bit
here is a controller joint which has
physical buttons for users to operate
the nanoleaf lines there are few modes
which range from controlling the
brightness the color effects having the
light sync to your music in what nano
leaf calls the rhythm music visualizer
this is the only section that has a wire
leading to the power adapter and
processor for the nano leaf lines behind
all these drawings are sticky strips and
pads which are grippy just like the ones
you get from 3m is a good idea to
download the nanoleaf app to get an idea
of the design you like with their layout
assistant
otherwise nanoleaf has a few sample
designs to get you inspired as well
designing your own nano leaf lines is
relatively simple it can get really
creative with your design the simplest
tip i can give you here is to lay it out
on a table or floor and get started it's
really down to your creativity and you
need some inspiration you can find some
layouts online too the great thing about
nanoleaf is that you can change your
designs as and when you like now that
it's all nicely laid out it's time to
put it up on the wall but before that
let's talk about today's sponsor
logitech here at gate culture audio is a
huge part of our daily lives both work
and playing so what's our choice of
headphones well i mean the logitech g435
light speed gaming wireless headset it
lets you listen to all the rich sounds
from your music videos and games across
pc console and mobile while spotting
some popping vibrant colors not only
that you only weighs 165 grams which
means sometimes you even forget you're
wearing it with the robust battery life
of 18 hours you can enjoy your gaming
sessions for prolonged periods of time
for more details head over to
logitechg.com i do recommend getting an
extra pair of hands this way it's easy
to mark all the spots where i want the
joints aligned before sticking them on
in the event you made a mistake along
the way the joints are actually easily
removable and replaced as well so the
lack of permanence is a good thing with
this product
there's a bit of flex with the lines
which help with minute adjustments to
keep everything straight and aligned
for those who are a little ocd having a
tool such as a level might help you out
a lot the positioning of the power joint
is also important here and we recommend
to place it where it is closest to the
floor you might not face this issue if a
dry wall or a false wall but for the
majority of home owners wire concealment
is a main concern with the nano leaf
lines
so
some pre-planning is necessary
and there you have it guys just look at
how the nano leaf glows
the lines simply look amazing
plus this is not even in total darkness
as well it lights up really well and on
lighter colored walls the colors really
radiate evenly there's a few ways to
control the device ranging from the
mobile app to even the desktop app
itself if you're looking to have the
lights replicate the color palette of
your desktop you can do it here as well
the nano leaf mobile app like most apps
takes a while to get used to you can
tell that the app design is not quite
polished and you might encounter some
bugs along the way
all in all it still does the job now
that it's all set up you have the option
to pair the nano leaf together with
other home automation services like
google home or apple homekit setting up
the device is straightforward and simple
i got this up in about 5 minutes flat
plus i can set up voice commands to turn
it on and off and change the colors
the next cool feature here is having the
leaf lines react to your music as well
this is especially great for parties if
you're a music streamer what's
interesting is that the tech works of an
inbuilt microphone which we understand
is not connected to the cloud in any way
but if you're a privacy advocate this is
something to be mindful of final
thoughts on the nano leaf lines honestly
feel that it's a fantastic product from
the end-to-end experience
the only issue here is the price tag
associated with it
expect to pay about 199 us dollars for
this or about 339 singapore dollars for
the starter kit
with the expansion kit containing three
lines this goes up to about 109
singapore dollars
this might be a deal breaker for some
i'd say if you were priced more
affordably this would be immediate buy
for myself and for anyone looking to get
into this aesthetic
the great part about the nano leaf lines
is how the leds are backlit and not
shining directly outwards this makes it
superior compared to other nano leaf
designs when it comes to practicality
what you get here is a hit turner to
anyone who is going to chill in your
room it does give you a different fight
honestly it's something you can just
stay at and be dazzled
it's really a cool gadget to have in
your home and
you can even have this as a centerpiece
in your living room there we have it my
rundown of the entire nanoleaf
experience from end to end
is this something you're looking to get
what are your thoughts let me know in
the comment section below and i'll be
happy to answer any questions and while
you're down there do give this video
like and subscribe to our channel it
really goes a long way
i'm gero from geek culture and i'll see
you in the next one
[Music]